[Musica]
e se vi dicessi che è possibile lavorare
dalla sicilia per milano londra new york
a distanza mantenendo le proprie
ambizioni lavorative ma al contempo
migliorando la propria qualità della
vita se me l'avessi detto l'anno scorso
prima della pandemia covip
probabilmente mi avreste risposto che
non era possibile e invece oggi in
qualche modo lo è ed è forse una delle
poche lezioni positive che abbiamo
tratto da questo anno terribile il 2020
che ci ha costretti a cambiare non solo
abitudini ma anche luoghi in cui vivere
e lavorare e priorità questa è la foto
del mio ufficio in lussemburgo dove
vivevo prima della pandemia lavorando e
l'università come sinistra di ricerca
questa invece è la foto del mio attuale
ufficio qui a catania
a prima vista possono sembrare simili un
computer dei libri dei quaderni ma in
verità in questo anno è cambiato tutto
mi chiamo elena sono nata a palermo nel
1992 e mi sono trasferita come molti
della mia generazione al nord per
studiare dopo il liceo nel 2010
in questi dieci anni ho avuto la
possibilità di fare molte esperienze
stimolanti sia di studio e di lavoro
prima a milano e poi all'estero ma
sempre con una nostalgia di sottofondo
della mia terra la sicilia che restava
in qualche modo utopica e irrealizzabile
ed invece con lo scoppio della pandemia
nel 2020 il mio datore di lavoro mi ha
dato la possibilità di lavorare a
distanza e sono quindi è rientrata a
marzo del 2020
in sicilia e non sono più andata via mi
sono ri trasferita in sicilia dove oggi
vivo fra palermo catania e messina
chi è questo ragazzo lui il mio amico
paul un mio amico americano che è
conosciuto a los angeles nel 2018
lavorava nel settore immobiliare del
reale state e faceva avanti e indietro
fra new york e los angeles
oggi invece lavora dalla sicilia da un
paese che si chiama santo stefano di
camastra in provincia di messina
e continua a svolgere il suo lavoro a
distanza
chi è questa coppia nella mia collega
benedetta una mimica di napoli che prima
della pandemia viveva in sudafrica a
città del capo dove lavoravano il
settore della consulenza alle imprese
oggi anche lei consumi danzato luca
lavorando in sicilia e continuano a
svolgere il loro lavoro appunto a
distanza cosa hanno in comune queste tre
storie
siamo tutti e quattro rientrati in
italia o abbiamo deciso di venire in
italia proprio a causa dello scoppio
della pandemia che per la prima volta ci
ha dato la possibilità di scoprire la
possibilità di lavoro da remoto è in
qualche modo ci ha permesso di
realizzare dei desideri che dovevamo da
molti anni in maniera inconscia o
comunque non realizzata
non siamo però gli unici in realtà siamo
in ottima compagnia
tantissimi lavoratori e lavoratrici
hanno avuto la possibilità nel 2020 di
lavorare a distanza dal sud o delle aree
interne del paese lontani dai grandi
distretti produttivi urbani o
addirittura dall'italia per l'estero
e in effetti abbiamo anche delle stime
lo svimez ha infatti stimato che nel
2020 siano stati circa 100 mila i
lavoratori che hanno usufruito di queste
modalità di lavoro da questi luoghi ed
erano spesso persone che erano andate
via dopo dei nostri territori per
trovare migliore opportunità di studio o
di lavoro
ed in effetti la situazione da quindi un
uomo via prevedeva un
tasso di occupazione molto basso
soprattutto per i giovani e soprattutto
per le donne
in effetti nella mia situazione una
giovane donna siciliana ha solo una
possibilità su tre di essere occupata e
al contempo negli ultimi anni è
aumentata sempre di più la percentuale
di persone giovani e laureate che si
reca all'estero dopo la laurea per
lavorare in effetti la corte dei conti
ha misurato un incremento del 41,3 per
cento negli ultimi otto anni
proprio per questo motivo questo
fenomeno di ritorno nel 2020 è stato
così straordinario in effetti non
soltanto io ma tantissimi giovani hanno
iniziato a immaginare che questo possa
essere un segno di cambiamento per il
futuro e abbiamo dato un nome questo
fenomeno south working lavorare dal sud
con l'idea di avanzare delle proposte
oltre l'emergenza non soltanto quindi il
telelavoro emergenziale da casa che
abbiamo svolto con molti però e
moltissimi contro in questo primo anno
di appunto tele lavoro forzato ma la
proposta di un nuovo tipo di lavoro un
lavoro a distanza che sia anche lavoro
agile per obiettivi cicli e fasi che
cambia anche quindi il modo di
immaginare il lavoro non più basato su
timbrare il cartellino ma invece sul
raggiungimento di obiettivi che porti al
miglioramento della produttività con un
approccio di vantaggio reciproco fra il
datore di lavoro è il lavoratore che lo
desidera e questo lavoro in south
worthing non sarà svolto da casa
in quell isolamento ho vissuto in questo
anno ma quando sarà possibile
sarà svolto da luoghi di lavoro
condiviso spazi di coworking che noi
chiamiamo presidi di comunità luoghi in
cui i lavoratori south worker possono
non soltanto incontrarsi fra loro ma
anche incontrare le comunità locali
partecipare alla vita dei luoghi che
decidono di abitare e in qualche modo
restituire quanto appreso altrove
a queste comunità in un'ottica di chi
back proprio di ridare indietro qualcosa
ai luoghi che si amano
cosa può dare il soft walking ai
territori in cui lavoratori si spostano
in realtà il miglioramento che si può
avere non è soltanto individualistico
rispetto alla qualità della vita
percepita dal singolo cover e anche
molti aspetti positivi sui territori in
cui si va a lavorare quanto meno per dei
periodi in effetti questo spostamento di
capitale umano di giovani professionisti
ad avere degli effetti positivi in
termini non soltanto di consumi e quindi
dell'inizio né di liquidità immediata
derivante dal spendere il proprio
stipendio del luogo in cui si vive ma
anche in termini di eco sistema creativo
di nuove idee di investimenti non
soltanto immobiliari ma anche in società
in start up e di nuovo volontariato di
nuova linfa alle comunità in qualche
modo anche in termini di nuove proposte
di miglioramento dei servizi e delle
infrastrutture che spesso vediamo come
oggettivamente carenti o poco efficienti
e che invece possono beneficiare delle
nuove proposte che giungono dai soggetti
che hanno vissuto anche in luoghi molto
diversi proprio per questo ci domandiamo
quali sono le criticità che abbiamo
affrontato in questo primo anno di south
working in maniera molto realistiche
oggettiva dobbiamo dirci che ci sono
ancora delle criticità che possono
essere ravvisate per questo abbiamo
bisogno che si realizzino quantomeno dei
pre requisiti minimi per poter lavorare
a distanza dai nostri territori
sicuramente i soft worker non seguono il
paradigma tradizionale che ci hanno
imposto per anni di attesa del
miglioramento dei servizi delle
infrastrutture ai livelli del centro
nord o dell'estero per poi attendere che
vengano impiantate noi le imprese ed
infine attendere che si agisca sui
bassissimi tassi di occupazione invece i
suoi fuorché air hanno iniziato da loro
stessi dal lavoro che potevano svolgere
da qui per poter poi attrarre appunto
nuove imprese e per poter poi
contribuire anche al mio
momento di servizi e infrastrutture ma
pur con questo ottimismo
alcune di queste infrastrutture sono
necessarie in particolare tre una buona
connessione internet che sia stabile e
veloce in maniera tale da poter lavorare
con soggetti che sono sparsi per il
mondo
ma al contempo garantire l'affidabilità
della propria connessione un sistema di
trasporti possibilmente pubblici che
permette di recarsi presso la sede del
datore di lavoro o presso i clienti
quando necessario e quindi quantomeno un
trasporto entro due ore da un aeroporto
o da una fazione ad alta velocità ed
infine la presenza di luoghi in cui
lavorare in maniera condivisa di questi
presidi comunità spazi che possono
essere recuperati anche dai luoghi poco
utilizzati o addirittura i utilizzati
sia pubblici sia privati e che
permettano proprio di creare questa
relazione fra is auto worker e le
comunità locali come avvenuto a
castelbuono dove i ragazzi
dell'associazione locale insieme al
comune hanno riattivato una serie di
spazi comunali fra cui una parte di un
castello del 1300 ed infatti gli impatti
per le comunità e per i nostri territori
per il sud per la sicilia per le aree
interne possono essere tantissimi non
soltanto in termini di nuovo spostamento
di soggetti ma anche di attrazione di
nuove idee e quindi ai auto worker
possono rappresentare estremi di
cambiamento o semi di trasformazione per
le nostre città e per i nostri territori
che vadano a migliorare non soltanto le
loro qualità della vita ma anche i
luoghi che li circondano partecipando in
prima persona alle nuove proposte e al
miglioramento di servizi e
infrastrutture solo sporting e
rappresenta una possibilità per i nostri
territori per immaginare un nuovo sud
possibile uno in cui il cambiamento sia
all'ordine del giorno in cui la mia
generazione la nostra generazione nelle
più giovani possono rappresentare parte
attiva del cambiamento e non più
soltanto andare via
[Musica]